James this is such a personal story
talk about writing it and
what made you want to
share this with the world
I have I mean the three kids that I have
they're now too old they don't care
about me anymore but back several years
ago they really liked bedtime stories
and always liked the stories most of my
childhood
and sometimes I would change the ending
frankly to make them Happier Endings
but they were really interested in one
time my wife and I were driving over the
59th Street Bridge
and they said Dad we want to see where
you grew up
so we pulled off Queens Boulevard and I
don't know if anybody knows New York
here but we basically went to my house
and it was way smaller than I remembered
it and my kids sort of looked at it and
went ah
and I remember seeing my neighbor
looking out the window who might
recognized and he I didn't talk to him
frankly I was avoiding him because I
knew his wife had died not too long
before that and I I realized there was
very little evidence actually that I had
ever lived there there was some paint on
the wall where I used to make my little
model rockets but that was about it and
I became uh very melancholy in a way
that I didn't quite expect
and I started to realize I mean then my
father was still alive and my my brother
thank heavens is but everybody else in
the movie my mother my grandparents my
grandmother all gone
and how ephemeral it all is and how all
those momentous dinners which seem so
important
there's no evidence of those people and
of those dinners and that filled me with
a certain emotion I suppose I kind of
wanted to bring them back to life in a
way even if they're not 100 beautiful uh
to our eye you know
I love that and talking about you know
and changing the endings I mean your
editor Scott I did not change the ending
on this picture
but talk about working with Scott and
how you know that phone call that you
got from James
and what did he say to you about this
film
I don't remember I'm going to be
interested to hear this I have no
recollection at all what did I say let's
hear it Scott well you're
um yeah it was a great phone call to get
your um
you're kind of wonderful and
you pretty much just asked me to do it
and why don't you tell that we'd worked
together we were slaving away on other
pictures he's acting we were just
randomly call them up I come to the
movie
no we worked together on uh lost city Z
and at Astra and at Astra went on for
two years and we got very close
um as that film went through a lot of
revisions and um yeah I mean I trained
with um John Knox Radley Haugen on those
other two films and you know uh John
wasn't available to do this and he'd
recommended me and James and I had that
relationship so it was a natural you
know call to get and it's just such an
honor you know to be kind of learning
from James over the years and then to
have him ask her to do this such an
honor to learn from me what are you
talking about it's such a nice man he's
such a nice young man
so full of it we were it's in the
trenches you know you make a film right
you're struggling it's everything's
Australia is that going to make any
sense anybody is that going to work
narratively is that boring whatever you
know and he's saying I learned so much
and he's such a nice man how early did
you bring him into the process as early
as I possibly could I I'm you know the
whole thing has been nuts I mean I'm
obviously not the only person I'm the
only person who had gone through the
pandemic by the way I'm the only person
no the pandemic made everything nuts you
know when we we had a cast lined up and
then the world ended and had to recast
and everyone's schedule changed and
John's schedule saying you're just gonna
Darius kanji the cemetery is his
schedule changed somehow we got it all
together at some point the script was
written in 2019 which is very weird
because you know context has its way
with you sometimes your hostage to it
sometimes your beneficiary of it but you
know it was pre-january 6th it was pre
George Floyd's pre-black lives matter
pre-election contesting all that stuff
and it seems more topical now
than it did even when I wrote it which
I'm not proud of actually but that's a
whole other conversation
I don't know how do I get into that I'm
sorry
but I wanted to talk about your casting
Jeremy Strong is phenomenal and Hathaway
Anthony Hopkins and of course finding
Banks like how did you find
Banks to play Paul well I loved both
those boys for uh they went through the
same process which was
I mean first of all I had a great
casting directors guy named Doug Abel
I've worked with for many many years
but I said to him I said cast and I said
well do you want to limit it to New York
I said well you can if you want but I
think you have to see the whole country
and really that was one of the Dumber
things I said because I think I saw 600
tapes
which is a lot
and my morning ritual you know I'd open
up the laptop
and I have my cup of coffee
and it would be like my casting director
would you know zoom in say today you
have 107.
and you can't start at the you know you
can't start and then just cut it off or
whatever because sometimes the kids
would warm up and be beautiful in the
middle sometimes the kid would start
strong and then Peter out sometimes
you'd if you'd want to weigh in and give
them an adjustment so you couldn't sort
of like
just zoom through it or something or
Zoom three can't say that I would speed
through it you had to see each kid
and this kid uh the main character Banks
Jalen's a little bit of a different
story about how I found him but Banks uh
he's from North Carolina
and has absolutely nothing to do with
the character in the film
but he's unbelievably intelligent and he
listens and what I found with with the
boys was that they were great at
improvising and they were so bright
because they could they could listen and
and throw it right back at me when I
threw them curveballs during the
auditions but that's really that's it's
just there's no magic in a way you just
have to go nuts and bolts through it I
just want to go back to what you said
about you know the timeliness of the
film
um you know it doesn't feel moralizing
at all it feels like you know you
discuss racial you know injustices and
social social inequalities like talk
about getting that balance right
like
well first of all I thank you for that
but I but what I would say is I'm glad
you felt I got it right but that
I felt it was very important to not have
an answer a solution
and that I would fail I thought it was
very important that I failed
in the film because
it's very easy to be a superhero I don't
mean that literally like a comic book
movie but I mean a superhero in the
sense that you solve all the world's
problems in your film and the character
does and that wasn't the way that I saw
it in my childhood in my childhood what
happened was instead of getting answers
I got thrown into a greater sense of
what I'll call cognitive dissonance
and one of the things I tried to
communicate we tried to commute iei we
tried to communicate
um
so Tony Hopkins he says to me says
your name is graph that's a better name
you're going to fit in
and I I told your parents to do that in
other words he's the one who actually
does
totally uh abandoned the public school
system and he's the one who says fit in
but then the next scene he says be a
good guy be a mensch which is a
cognitive cognitive dissonance for the
kid even the person who loves him the
most and he loves the most is sending
him unbelievably confusing messages
and what I was trying to say
is that you can be the oppressor and the
oppressed at the same time and that it
is not easy to unravel the web that
we've created for ourselves and each
other in the culture
and that oftentimes a point fingers
immoralized you know you're stupid
you're an idiot whatever it's it's
more tricky than that and at the same
time that something awful would happen
to Johnny
I would see Fred Trump saying what's
your last name
Christan what kind of name is that and I
knew what he was saying and I was 12. I
knew exactly what he was trying to do so
my point was that it's it's an unending
series of layers and
um no one is really at fault per se but
we're all to blame
talk about finding the perfect house
which is basically your childhood home
you know
my house
which is 90 feet south from where we
shot uh we went the first thing we did
just we went and rang the doorbell of my
house
and she didn't answer
and she was a Chinese my father had sold
her the house she was Chinese and so
um didn't speak English so I then of
course had a friend of ours who was who
spoke Mandarin come to try and talk with
her and then it became clear that
actually the problem wasn't the language
problem the problem is she didn't want a
large film crew wrecking her house
I we found a woman whom I knew and went
to high school with who lived about
Three Doors Down who was dumb enough I
mean nice enough to let us take over her
house now the houses were all built in
that in literally 1946 right after the
war all this kind of cookie cutter
Archie Bunker neighborhood
the house the neighborhood itself has
changed completely when I grew up there
we were the lone Jewish Family on the
Block it was like I said totally Archie
Bunker and my neighbor that we shared
that house with because it was a
semi-attached row house
he looked talked acted exactly like
Carol O'Connor in on the family except
that his name was uh Charlie not Archie
and I remember he he put the flagpole in
just a little bit to his side and he
would say hey you got to find out who
the regular Americans out to live in
this house I fought in a big one the WW2
I fought in a big one like that's the
way he's talked and I remember once
though my father said something pretty
great to me once that there was a
gardener who was Latino I don't know if
he was Mexican but what the the Charlie
would say was the Mexican here we see
the Mexican is here whatever he would
say terrible things about the guy and my
father said to me once when I was
standing the next room I was probably
about 11.
um
he left and he said do you hear the way
he's talking about the gardener I said
yeah he said well we're not around
that's the way he talks about us and I
remember kind of going
okay uh and you sort of semi-process it
but that was the neighborhood now it's
almost exclusively Asian or Orthodox
Jewish which is very weird which means
the food is way better than it ever was
when I grew up
um but you see it in the film uh we very
minimal visual effects work uh the
crosswalk maybe had a new painted street
sign maybe there were a couple of things
but the garbage cans are different other
than that it was the same maybe we
painted out some satellite dishes I
think but that public school where
they're walking in the beginning of the
movie that's my public school PS 173 in
Queens
um the street where they see the movie
Private Benjamin that's the street Fresh
Meadow Lane right near my house no Fresh
Meadow by the way anywhere near the
neighborhood but that was the street
name which is a little weird so you see
it all there warts and all what is it
like having the film out there for
people to see and getting this feedback
it's very strange because uh it's like a
home movie so I kind of am
simultaneously thrilled and horrified
you know somebody says they love it you
feel like you just won the lottery
somebody says they hate it it means they
hate part of you
so
I can only tell you that I tried to make
it as honestly as I could we tried to
make it as honestly as we could not
not sugar-coated
Thomas Hardy the writer he once said if
a way to the better there be it lies in
taking a full look at the worst
and I kind of thought
for this movie that makes sense
including by the way for myself I wasn't
anxious to make myself look like a hero
or somebody great and it was all part of
that Mo show it you know the world as
you think it was not as you wish it were
thank you everybody for coming out on a
Sunday night thank you James and thank
you thank you so congratulations thank
you thank you